on to other news here at five after days
of behind the scenes work Nevada
lawmakers are making some changes to a
bill that would help fund a stadium for
the A's here in Las Vegas 8 news now
reporter Brian will has been following
the progress of the bill and Brian where
do things stand as of tonight yeah
Denise that bill has passed and cleared
two of the hurdles getting voted out of
committee and the Senate it currently
sits on the assembly floor this
afternoon it needs 22 votes to pass the
assembly and then it would make its way
to Governor Joe Lombardo's desk the bill
passed the committee and the Senate vote
with two amendments that Governor
Lombardo vetoed in the regular session
one is an exception to pay prevailing
wages in certain monorail projects the
other is a requirement for companies to
provide 12 weeks of paid family leave
it'll be up to the assembly to decide if
those amendments stay
I believe that there are Provisions in
this legislation that have
put more restrictions into actually
delivering for the the people of the
state I will say this I'm going to vote
no
not because I have something against
jobs but there are other jobs there are
other members of Labor who have said to
me their jobs may be on the line and so
I'm going to side with them
the bill would make the Tropicana site
the only one for the ballpark and ensure
the A's remain in Las Vegas for at least
30 years a community benefits agreement
was reached which includes support of
Youth Baseball educational programs with
local colleges scholarships internships
and donations of tickets and Suites for
Community organizations the aids would
contribute at least one and a half
million dollars per year to those
programs now this is the fourth day of
the special session on this bill which
would give the A's up to 380 million
dollars in public financing to help
construct the 1.5 billion dollar Stadium
if approved the stadium could be ready
in time for opening day in the spring of
2028 in the studio Brian will 8 News Now